yo Bole C podcast special guest in here
representing Reno
Nevada shout out to Reno you're the
first person I know from Reno for real
yeah that's man how is it in Reno
[__] small it's [__] to do though is
prostitutes legal
there yeah how yeah yeah in Vegas
they're not I used to live in Vegas well
it's like to an extent like you feel me
you got to drive like to like a
different County Clark County is the
only I think the only County in Nevada
where escorts Ain are prostitutes right
now out there bro brothels are popping
out there right yeah you haven't been to
one yet you're 18 yeah I'm 18 we got to
take some of that advaned money you're
getting and take it straight over to the
czy run it up
crazy shout out to Reno Nevada L Dey is
here uh what do you got coming anything
you want to plug before we have you do
your thing
man yeah
um
Tails from the
north yeah tell Tails from the north to
coming man say how do I know your [__]
man you preu Russ don't even don't even
be knowing my [__] sometimes you
forgetting sometimes y tell from nor to
coming real soon coming real soon man
I'm excited for this one you're only 18
y I'm 18 are you still in school uh no I
graduated uh last year or this year
there it is man let's get right to it
Loop Dey Reno Nevada in the building
come
on
[__] smart as World [__]
look that's that I still miss my granny
life but that's that lost my right hand
is here that's that my face be covered
in tears from the flashbacks [__] ain't
[__] with the kid and that's that
plus the last that mentioned us in the
track I clapped that [__] you ain't my
brother we acquainted that's that
different say i s I know I'm back sing I
spend majority of my minutes trying to
make it out this town rather you stay
but with straight when you wasn't around
see I tend to never cry so it's violence
If Tears touch ground you say I clap
this block I said I never heard such
sound I'm spinning and spinning I might
just spin this [__] again spin it to
the neck why would I risk it with a
friend [__] he said he was going to
kill me you going to kick it with that
man but that's my fault I should been
sticking to the plan cuz it's [__] a
[__] and [__] any man if you ask little
binary trigger you finger it it's going
to bust too I only trust you I'm lying I
don't trust the S the F you got to face
it Ain L if you want to touch his nose
game time you got your cleats cuz I lace
mine just SL me as it s me a marar snake
with the same slime now you ha a [__] G
that's a change mind scream any name I'm
pulling up when you say m [__] that's
how I'm to ride I guesso going keep on
wolfing like he PO is Glide I want to
meet my brother's killer but they got
him locked I think I got to watch cuz if
bro was freeding we stop this clock real
store I've had some questions since they
kill more like can Heaven hold Thug cuz
God love he for I don't judge the thugs
for drugs they can't manage but I truly
loved you more but of course you would
take advantage that explain it all [__]
that's that I still miss my granny life
but that's that lost my right hand this
year that's that my face be covered in
tears from the flashbacks [__] they
ain't [__] with the kid that's that
plus the last I mentioned us in the
track I CLA that [__] ain't my brother
we acquainted that's that different time
I saw I know I'm back sending [__] woo
L Dey [__] there it is bootle podcast
let's go Tails from the north to coming
soon by the way couple weeks you feel me
go run it up hey appreciate you guys
watching this freestyle we got another
one coming and then another one and then
another one and they're all brought to
you by our good Folks at LRG clothing
you already know what it is LRG been
keeping you fly for years they got so
much new fly gear right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30% off
l-r-g.com
another freestyles on the way presented
by LRG